now then the australian prime minister
scott morrison has said he's yet to
decide whether he'll be attending cop 26
the un climate change conference in
november and he joins the likes of
china's president xi jinping who's also
yet to confirm if he'll be attending the
summit in glasgow
so without leaders of the world's
biggest countries how much could the
summit achieve well let's discuss this
now mike berners-lee to you first of all
does it really matter if the likes of
scott morrison or xi jinping are
actually there in person they'll have
delegations in glasgow won't they do do
you need the people themselves there
well possibly not quite necessarily but
it's an important opportunity to send
out a message about how much you care
about this huge issue and you know here
we are in a climate emergency
and just to be clear you know nobody
anyone should be giving any time of day
to
any politician that doesn't take climate
really really seriously
and show coherent uh policies uh that
demonstrate that they mean it um and at
least of all voting for them so you know
i think it's sending out certainly um
the wrong message for sure
jen allen do you agree with that i mean
how important do you think it is
symbolically that leaders are actually
there having face-to-face meetings
they're there in person
it's actually fairly rare that
we will see heads of state
show up at a climate meeting and
sometimes they've been pretty
counterproductive
so maybe conversely this shows that
they have to deny the invitation
so it shows that cop is a chance to put
public pressure and political pressure
on leaders and so maybe that function of
cop is actually working because we're
talking about these major emitters that
may not send their leaders we still need
their pledges to be updated but you know
that could be an email
well that's interesting and in fact as
you say it's not just about turning up
it's what's decided there isn't it let's
take a look at what the un head has said
he said either we're united or we're
doomed so what do you think mike
it's not just about persuading world
leaders to turn up it's getting
consensus when they're there so how do
you do that
well i mean the the quote you've just
given sums up the big picture on what
the situation we've got now so either
our humanity is going to learn to
cooperate at the global level
quickly far better than it's ever done
before
uh or it's pretty clear that we're going
to head to a pretty dark place in the in
the in the reasonably near future so
that is the you know that's the um
that's the sort of top line of it so how
do we get about that cooperation one of
the things is we we need to find a way
of this working for every for everyone
and and all states and one of the things
that would be really helpful to
uh to give the cop its best chance would
be to sending at least be sending out
messages that we care about each other
and that we and that we cooperate so for
example how we deal with the vaccines in
the pandemic um you know would be one
way that we could be sending out
messages that we are capable of of
looking out for each other and coming to
arrangements that everyone can live with
at the end of the day we are almost
certainly going to need a carbon price
to keep the fuel in the ground and
somehow that price needs to be
implemented in such a way that as i say
everybody can live with it do you think
that's right some kind of carbon price
do we need some kind of stick as well as
a carrot to get consensus do you think
at cop26 jen is that important that's
the way to go
there's very few sticks in global
cooperation i'm afraid uh
i think we need to start looking beyond
cop26 and what we're seeing is climate
being woven into other areas of global
cooperation like security announcements
that were made recently
so we can start realizing that
just like the pandemic has influenced so
many parts of our lives climate change
is going to do the same thing and it's
going to touch on many areas of
cooperation at the global level
and we're going to start building
incentives to act on climate into trade
agreements into security agreements into
humanitarian and food related agreements
and that will increase the pressure to
act on climate because if we don't then
all of those other agreements will start
to fail
you